es ist ein traum winter in bad gastein
und kaum einer merkt
die gondeln laufen aber die gastronomie
ist geschlossen
nur einheimische dürfen die pisten
genießen
und die sind vorsichtig halten abstand
man sieht nunmehr skitourengehen corona
verändert aber noch mehr zurück so
ausgesinn liche oder bad gastein in
wartestellung nicht nur wegen corona
teile des alten kurorts ins seit
jahrzehnten im dornröschenschlaf
der count care glanz verblasst was einst
die besten häuser waren rottet vor sich
[Musik]
doch gerade der marode charme verzaubert
einige seit ein paar jahren kommen
künstler neue gäste ein kunstfestival
entstand als einer der ersten hat er
hier ist setzte thomas picard auf den
lifestyle trend die korona zwangspause
nutzte nach corona fährt die urbanen
mittelklasse nur ungern weit weg meinte
siebel trendigen komfort und sicherheit
deshalb bauen sie eine autobahn mit
fußbodenheizung
ich hoffe dass ein anderes verhalten
kommt also wir sind der historische kurz
erwähnt wir sind jetzt nicht wo wir
dicht gedrängt auf einander stehen wie
in manchen bars in anderen orten
das wollen wir gar nicht haben was sie
wollen ist am abend thema bei einem
strategietreffen sie fühlen sich als
erneuerer der hotellerie sie sind aus
münchen hamburg oder von hier durch die
krise jetzt kommen sie mit
regierungshilfen und einem umsatzplus im
sommer dank corona glaube dass die leute
einfach so eine werks hin zu haben und
ich habe diesen zug diesen leuten und
das werden sie ihr befreundeten flieger
steigen und eben nur einen strand
fliegen zu uns fallen après ski und
massentourismus sind für länger auf
meint thomas kraft wieder mehr klasse
wollen die neuen lifestyle hotels mehr
kunst
kultur am ort das war nicht in
unterstrich demokratische weise konto
als er weiß natürlich wieder ein import
ist der natürlich zum teil auch
aufgesetzt dies teilweise wächst aus dem
ort heraus ganz wichtig dabei ist das
natürlich wir draußen ein anderes profil
und ein anderes image bekommen coruna
stärkt auch altbewährtes
ein thermalbad im eigenen haus anbieten
zu können
darauf ist doris zwiebel stolz die
nachfrage steigt die menschen mehr wert
legen
dahinter folge finden und gefertigte zu
60 prozent stammgäste hat sie die kommen
oft mehrmals im jahr
sie schätzen dass ich nichts verändert
und es traditionell gemütlich ist muss
ich nicht dauernd neu erfinden
blumenschmuck und zirpen zimmer
sicherheit und berechenbarkeit sind zu
corona zeiten auch gefragt meint sie bad
gastein neue stärke ist die vielfalt die
schattenseite es könnte zu viel werden
ich denke man sollte beachten dass
einfach nicht zu viele menschen auf
einem platz hin dass man also mit dem
stichwort ober tourismus dass sich das
in grenzen hält
sie sagt das auch weil ein großer
konkurrent entsteht gleich drei ebenso
noble wie marode häuser kaufte vor
kurzem eine immobilien gruppe für gerade
mal 7,5 millionen
[Musik]
wesentlich mehr kostet es erzählt ihr
vertreter daniel eick wort den alten
glanz aufleben zu lassen
das ist der festsaal im vorigen frühjahr
speisten hier kaiser und könige das ziel
die gäste anwalt wort
in zwei jahren schon soll es wieder das
beste haus am platze werden jetzt erst
recht wir glauben tatsächlich dass
corona das ein trend den wir schon
hatten er unterstützt also dieser trend
zur regionalität der trend dazu sich mit
der region zu befassen sich mit der
geschichte zu befassen
doch nostalgie allein zieht nicht genug
das trendige von bad gastein ist ebenso
wichtig die pop up stores die
kunstinteressierte schicke szene so
erzählt daniel eick wort die erst
schaffe die erfolgs perspektive für die
millionen investition in das alte
korrupte dies für uns insofern
wahnsinnig wichtig weil die halten drei
war ist ja und weil die sowohl für
jungen wie für alt interessant ist und
auch unterschiedlich ist aber eben
interessiertes publikum bringen
corona beschleunigt bad gastein
erneuerung auch in der skyline 13
stockwerke hoch soll der moderne anbau
werden es braucht wetten für die neuen
gäste jeder wandel hat seinen preis